[Music]
for six months of the year crystal blue
lagoons appear in what would otherwise
look like your average desert making
lens ice marianas one of brazil's most
mysterious destinations lynn sois
Marianas is a national park located in
Brazil from January to June the area
becomes inundated with rainstorms the
rainwater collects between the sand
dunes creating thousands of clear water
lagoons some of these pools reach over
300 feet in length and can be over ten
feet deep with water temperatures as
high as 87 degrees visitors come from
far and wide to experience the pristine
conditions but arriving at these pools
is no easy feat and renting a
four-wheeler is a must the ride is rough
as you need to cross tight spaces and
navigate through rivers and puddles
learn sois Marianas visitors must enjoy
these pools while they can because come
dry season the spectacular landscape
vanishes and returns to its desert form
once again
[Music]
[Music]
yo Sunnah Roboto qua not antonov a shoe
not even tactic restored the reason you
know believe over their national mapper
multi on me let me see if they start
equality with a contacted electrical
network
Erica mission what River so lucky you're
able to keep the bestseller Vita
the island of you deli parts of La
Maddalena National Park sits on the
northern coast of Sardinia it's
considered to be one of the most
beautiful islands in the Mediterranean
Sea only accessible by boat
Maurer morandi the sole inhabitant first
arrived here 29 years ago and he never
left from the river to park as well
named his animal of superior hypocrisy
Steve abu dali people tour de cachoeira
Prima top of a Johnson and Ave start Oh
hopefully Fortuna and paraphrase
impossible to the presidentís but that a
nonsense you know the Bellas said of a
non-digital one benvenuti near la mia de
mora queen on arrival in electric
aperture on guitar to deepen le
photovoltaic in sutra meuk event a
pellet want a copy of an opportunity so
no four-cylinder doctors reopen consumer
in twister my older Vinitaly
the critical tutelage ethical warm
regard Almar became also general
Bell diverse so do not say they started
getting bad give an Okanagan s unit plug
the multi Simona made the turn in token
anthalie be on him bar know your zebra
debt okay your multi Simeon II see
committee repay the patient Maltese name
is shown a Libra issue no public a
no-hitter this one of my and city panic
resurrect the Carrasco a memo here couch
dominoes say I was coming more the
everything termination and even that to
impound botanical heck with the arrastia
generals were that important era vilya
in contaminate adorned enemy rocket
Arturo's you know no mantecato Nineveh
no telomere a personal John to t-con
cement ago cement a supportive OB
rossabi equivalent area medium tone
about Tilden to be killed security
plastic etcetera
I think Otto Ventana the future coconut
or about engaging Iran
hey you know so no pupillary maitake or
any premium yami-san Segway canceled I'm
a total ignition Oh POTUS entrare no
moledo comunicaciones show no permission
or a second okay Go diva solo
requestable esta mi cent even Sesenta to
Montego Astana your normal me trim it
aqua
[Music]
yester Tata molto bene site inventing
over on me omission Amaya mulatto the
Meno pretty referred or been bad
my career started in okay that Savita
physically not permit not City come Eva
being a petition or phobia to the Pope
so convinced Oliver anti from yourself
value shown on Cora move to serene
tranquil Aviva molto bene ocular solo
our mobile Delhi a Buddha listen doc ock
a minute but mayor PCC
[Music]
they call this stretch of the North
Shore the seven-mile miracle there's a
world-class surf break every hundred or
so yards we rescue up to a thousand
people a year definitely one of the most
dangerous stretches of beaches in the
world
my name is tau Hanuman and I've been a
lifeguard for 14 years here on the North
Shore I work here at AO Kai Beach Park
it's the home of the surf break Banzai
Pipeline which is a very dangerous wave
that breaks in very shallow water
it's such a critical wave that if you
fall down the chances of getting injured
of hitting the reef is very high even
when it's really small we have very
strong powerful rip currents it's very
easy to get swept out in the rip current
and not be able to make it back to shore
just yesterday the lifeguards made about
20 rescues knowing that the possibility
of drowning is very real you know
especially a large surf we all train my
training consists of running the beach
of swimming anything basically in my
area
but we do Mach rescues if the surf is
big I'll tell one of my partners hey go
go out and get pounded in the surf I'll
come get you with a rescue tube so he'll
go out and you know he's taking waves on
the head and you know see how fast we
can get to them
whatever the oceans gonna do if someone
needs help and you have to go get that
person you got to be ready to do that
you're putting yourself in a very risky
situation but knowing that your partner
has your back there's it builds a strong
sense of camaraderie we have a good
morale between us all we do this job for
the love of the job amazing if you can
save another person's life it's very
rewarding for sure
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
I just want to start and go and go and
go the longest amount of time that I can
draw before the tide kept sit and watch
the raining away my name is Jim Donovan
I draw in the sand to draw on the sand
it's a balance between a mental game and
a physical they're both equally
important I started drawing in the sand
a little more than 20 years ago I was
walking along the beach one day it just
came to me to use it as canvas I just
put my finger in the sand and made a
giant fish I became really really
obsessed with it I left behind the world
both of surfing and the job as a chef
and I just took everything it's a
drawing in the sand there's almost no
one in the whole world that did this
kind of thing I've drawn in the sand
around the world Australia Uruguay
Argentina Chile Russia increasingly a
commission but we're also in places
where others a nice patches have I think
I'll go do something there the one that
was ten miles in circumference in the
desert on dry lake to kiss world record
and largest art I've walked as much as
30 miles in one day which means about
seven or eight hours of walking I like
the stick probably the best because I
like to come down to the beach with
nothing the tools are sitting there on
the beach sticks to choose from and I'll
do my composition do a nice big drawing
and then I'll throw the stick away I'm
down with nothing and leave with nothing
for me that's most fulfilling choice of
how to do it
during the sand is the ultimate of in
the moment and I want to finish when the
tide is about to destroy the time this
is gonna change every day anything I do
down there is going to be gone and every
time I'm gonna have a big huge place to
try something new
[Music]